One of the great things about creating a sprawling
cinematic universe with dozens of characters
is that the inevitable storyline mistakes
made along the way don't have to be permanent.
"I'm listening."
Just like in the comics that came before them,
each new chapter in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
is an opportunity to reach back into the past,
clarify plot lines, and close plot holes.
And that's just what the minds behind Avengers:
Infinity War say they did on the revealing
commentary track for the epic nineteenth movie
in the MCU.
Warning: massive spoilers ahead!
Directors Joe and Anthony Russo sat down with
co-writers Christopher Markus and Stephen
McFeely to break down how they wrangled ten
years' worth of buildup into one cohesive
climax.
There are a ton of great insights into lingering
questions about the two-and-a-half-hour blockbuster,
including what has long been considered a
plot hole in the very first Avengers flick
from 2012, written and directed by Joss Whedon.
You remember the scene: Natasha Romanoff,
Tony Stark and Steve Rogers have Loki in custody
on the Avengers' Quinjet, when all of a sudden,
Thor crashes down like lightning, knocks Stark
to the floor, grabs his bro, and bails.
But how did Thor actually get to Earth from
Asgard, when he destroyed his typical mode
of space travel, the rainbow-colored Bifrost
Bridge, at the end of the first Thor movie?
Remember: Avengers takes place before the
events of Thor: The Dark World, so the bridge
had yet to be rebuilt.
Thor doesn't explain how he made it to Earth
in the first Avengers outing, but Loki assumes
it has something to do with "dark energy":
"With the Bifrost gone how much dark energy
did the Allfather have to muster to conjure
you here?
Your precious Earth."
In the Infinity War commentary track, co-writer
Christopher Markus says crediting "dark energy"
for the trip always seemed like, quote, "a
bit of a paste job", sorry, Joss!, so they
added a callback in Infinity War to bolster
it.
The comment comes during an early Infinity
War scene when the Hulk, beaten badly by Thanos
in one-on-one combat, gets magically beamed
back to the Earth by the Asgardian Heimdall,
the former guardian of the Bifrost.
Heimdall's use of "dark magic," which comes
right before his ultimate sacrifice, allows
the Avengers to have some crucial time to
prepare themselves before Thanos' arrival,
which makes all the difference in their ability
to resist his invasion as much as they do.
Addressing unnamed critics who called the
whole magical "dark energy" explanation from
the first Avengers movie a "cheat," Markus
says Heimdall's summoning of "dark magic"
in Infinity War can now be seen as clear evidence
that Loki's assumption was correct:
"You just saw where the dark magic came from:
straight out of Heimdall."
Thankfully, this vague "dark energy" travel
is no longer necessary for Thor, who is more
than capable of bridging the cold expanse
of space on his own by the end of Infinity
War.
His new Bifrost-summoning axe Stormbreaker
is his new ride, bringing him to Wakanda for
the film's devastating climax.
And he'll need it for what's ahead in the
still untitled Avengers 4, due out May 2019,
which rumor has it will feature at least one
time-travel or flashback scene straight out
of the original Avengers flick.
So expect your understanding of the events
of that film to shift yet again.
Avengers: Infinity War will be out on 4K Blu-Ray,
standard Blu-Ray, and DVD on August 14th.
If you're itching to hear the full commentary
track, it's available as a digital download
from select outlets.